[Musique]
non ce n'est pas la nouvelle attraction
de la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux
mais plutôt une animation de prévention
routière souad et sa fille yasmine ont
participé à ces exercices
le but de cette voiture tonneau c'est
bien mettre la ceinture on va vous
m'expliquez certaines règles c'est des
automatismes ça prend quelques secondes
plusieurs stands de sensibilisation ont
été installés dans la cour de l'espace
culturel decauville afin que chacun
puisse mieux appréhender les dangers à
travers des masques les participants
vont pouvoir ressentir les symptômes de
l'alcool ou du cannabis et ainsi tester
leurs capacités physiques
alors vas tu je voyais rien je voyais
que le haut et je voyais comme une loupe
et le beh devait baisser la tête pour
pouvoir voir c'est pour pouvoir le faire
comprendre aux personnes quittaient ce
alors évidemment d'abord les adultes et
on peut le faire aussi à certains
enfants comprendre le comportement qu'on
peut avoir face à ce type de
consommation et par rapport à la le
comportement du cerveau par rapport à ce
type de message
la volonté du département et de réduire
la mortalité sur la route qui a la
mienne et 2017 et en os sur le
territoire en cause notamment l'alcool
la fatigue et la vitesse